it took a school a shiver a den a
clutter a skulk a herd and a whole pack
of artists to get the bad guys looking
sharp we're looking at the behind the
scenes and seeing how they compare to
what we saw on screen
number one don't you wish you had a
dance partner who could just spin you
around like gravity doesn't make sense
one thing you may or may not know about
animation is that artists rely on
real-life sources more often than not
and that means bringing in
choreographers to design the dance
sequences it makes total sense to us
however the problem with a movie like
the bad guys as opposed to something
like encanto is that these characters
are animated anthropomorphic animals say
that 10 times fast and so the animated
anthropomorphic animals have a far more
stylized movement and nothing is off the
table the choreographer susan meisner
had a leg up on the production though
excuse our puns as she had worked with
sam rockwell before and she knew the way
he moved and she just adored what saucy
brought to the table as she had a lot of
hips and sass i was hoping you were
gonna ask me to dance enough dancing
we've got a job to do
number two what time is it mr wolfe
we're gonna pretend to go good first up
we're taking a look at the big bad wolf
master of disguise a wolf in sheep's
clothes a wolf in grandma's glasses
no wait mr shark is the master of
disguise huh we really thought we were
going somewhere with that sam rockwell
was the first choice for the role of mr
wolfe hard to believe it wasn't george
clooney the usual suspect would have
been george clooney oh yeah no fool
clooney do not clooney me wolf but there
is nothing usual about this movie with
animated anthropomorphic animals so bye
clooney the concept art for mr wolfe is
quite fun if you get a strange sense
that it resembles sherlock hound your
instincts are correct keep trusting them
because the italian japanese animated
show sherlock hound was one of the many
influences on the movie it doesn't seem
like they ever considered the
round-faced mr wolf from the books
instead they played with all types of
body shapes and levels of deviousness mr
wolf's final suit may look paulus sorry
flawless but it went through 25
iterations before it was finalized nice
work now let's make like a wolf and get
the pack out of here number three or
should we call her the crimson paw from
doe eyed to muppety dianne foxington
went through quite the process to arrive
at the film-finished look we imagine the
concept artists preferred a similar
style of character to mr wolf to better
mirror their shared experience as bad
guys attempting to go good a wolf and a
fox are not so different she is loosely
based on a blond-haired fox from the
book series named ellen looks like she
took a bit of her own advice this is a
chance to write your own story to find a
better life for you and your friends
number four the design in the bad guys
is like nothing you've ever seen except
maybe a few things put in a blender the
look they were aiming for in the bad
guys was handmade and illustrated but
they really wanted to maintain a true
sense of physical light and volume this
movie borrowed from a ton of sources
director pierre pfeiffer admitted he had
an instant attraction to the book
because it mixes together his two
favorite things heist movies and
animated anthropomorphic animals the
director he was a 2d animation artist in
france for the first stretch of his life
so there is a strong influence of that
background on the film to craft the
style he borrowed from sources such as
ernest and celestine lupin iii the
castle of cagliostro hayao miyazaki and
sherlock hound which we mentioned
earlier a french sense of design
influenced by a lot of the anime style
he also took a lot of inspiration from
classic heist movies specifically
quentin tarantino's reservoir dogs that
inspiration came directly from the
original cover of the bad guys book and
i'm like oh my god this is perfect you
know animals gangsters driving cars
robbing banks but he also took from the
italian job ocean's 11 and soderbergh
films it's a weird combination much like
that of a piranha and a wolf teaming up
but we can follow their train of thought
number five professor marmalade sounds
like he belongs in paddington bear good
morning students of goodness diane
foxington isn't the only one who got a
name change oh goody in the books
professor marmalade is actually called
kajib blower
coin
if anybody's got pronunciation tips
we're all ears imagine the struggles of
the voice actors if they had to
pronounce that every time oh tiffany
it's not a competition and if it were it
would really be more of a tie what we
can't get past is the pointy guinea pig
teeth we would just like to direct your
attention up to the top corner of the
page to these beautiful little nuggets
of concept art
number six the design team decided to go
meta and set the movie in the place
where movies are made the la cityscapes
in the bad guys are just gorgeous the
design team wanted to replicate the smog
and white skies because the light is
very specific to la the skies are always
overblown and there are very specific
warm sun flares and to break out of the
cg-like world the artists were working
against the perfect cg shapes to bring
back in that 2d feeling the design team
was tasked with reinventing la as not
everything is pulled right from real
life an intentional choice to partially
avoid any legal repercussions but also
it gave them far more artistic freedom
in their designs it meant the team
needed to come up with plenty of single
buildings and street crops like
billboards palm trees telegraph posts
etc to create a library of individual
objects and to assemble them in sets
that evoke a certain neighborhood in los
angeles or that perhaps can give a vibe
of a real place that has been recreated
as opposed to just copied it can be way
easier now to do something with tons of
detail everywhere because of the
available tools
and it actually takes a lot of time and
energy to dismantle that to actually
make something that looks simple and
tasteful we imagine that's what happened
here marmalade's mansion went through so
much concept art same goes for the love
crater gala and park it looks like it
was ripped right out of the jetsons and
let's take a peek at the designs for the
vehicles in this movie while we're at it
number seven legs webs
miss tarantula she was originally a
mister named legs in the books and was
re-nicknamed webbs for the movie we can
see why calling her legs just wasn't a
good idea
she went through a lot of design
concepts from creepy to blue we are a
bit blue that they didn't keep the blue
well there goes our street cred perhaps
that's why they made her cute little
onesie blue but her design could make or
break the movie arachnophobes beware
eight legs eight times the cardio too
creepy and you risk losing your audience
i think we could be more than just scary
villains or smelly villains piranha
number eight we've gotta say we dig mr
snake's beach shirt his design didn't
change a whole lot how many ways can you
design a snake anyways well they did
give a shark legs so does that mean
oh yes look close at this concept art
just kidding those aren't legs that's
just his shirt
sucker but for real his concept art is
unsettling see the creepy zombie puppet
alligator faces yeesh
bad or go home
number nine mr shark was the master of
design as well as disguise we could have
had a pitch black mr shark or even a
hammerhead mr shark but neither of these
would have honored the book design hey
uh did you get him ahead don't mess with
perfection i got this number 10. mr
piranha was almost a suave fellow let's
do this sorry buddy it didn't happen
i ain't angry you're angry it would be
hard to imagine him with such a shrill
voice surprise
actually something about some of these
images gives us spongebob vibes can you
see it what
no i'm starting when i'm nervous finding
the right balance for mr piranha could
not have been easy number eleven in the
book tiffany fluff it was actually a cat
that explains the last name tiffany
flemit channel six action news the bad
guys have struck again if they'd kept
fluff at a cat we would have demanded a
reigning cats and dogs joke while she
did the news what we adore about the
concept art for her is all of the fun
hairstyles they were exploring for her
character and misty luggans didn't even
exist in the books by the looks of this
concept art the creative team had
considered making her a dude at one
point too we're happy with their
decision or else we wouldn't have the
vocal stylings of the great alex
borstein case
closed i win number 12 imagine being
washed away by a wave of guinea pigs
so fluffy
so
nightmarish have you ever wondered how
movies animate an army of zombie guinea
pigs no us neither well the zombie
guinea pig army as you can imagine took
a lot of work to create the bad guys
gives us hope for the future and not
just a sequel but that we will see more
unique art styles and lead characters
hollywood needed a real shake-up and we
don't say that just because this movie
was set in la what do you think of this
new generation of animation we've been
launched into from movies like into the
spider-verse to the mitchells versus the
machines to turning red and now this are
you liking that the studios are
switching up their art styles or do you
think what they already had was working
let us know your thoughts in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things